chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn hai cái thao tác định dạng đó là
định dạng chia cột tức là một đoạn văn
chúng ta có thể chia ra nhiều cột và
thao tác định dạng thứ hai đó là đình
dạng chữ hoa rớt dòng hay còn gọi là
drop cap giống như chữ N ở đây hoặc chữ
T hoặc chữ B ở
đây và chúng ta lưu ý rằng là trong một
đoạn văn mà có đồng thời đị
dạng vừa đị dạng drop C và vừa đị dạng
colum chia cuột thì chúng ta sẽ định
dạng chia cột trước và định dạng drop
cap sau rồi bây giờ chúng ta bắt đầu
chúng ta chọn đoạn văn thứ
nhất nhấp đôi
chuột chúng ta thực hiện thao tác chia
cột bằng cách vào layout chọn column
và chúng ta có thể chọn two three left
right Đó là các cái cách chia cột khác
nhau Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ chia hai cột
thì chúng ta chọn to
đây chúng ta có được hai hai Cột tiếp
tục chúng ta sẽ định dạng drop cat tức
là chữ N ghi hoa rớt dòng chúng ta đặt
con trọ tại vị trí chữ N vào thẻ Insert
chọn drop cat
và sau đó chúng ta có hai cái dàng đó là
drop pck và
ining thì thông thường nhất là chúng ta
dùng dạng drop Vy chúng ta sẽ nhấp chuột
vào
drop đây và chúng ta có được định Dảng
drop
cap đấy tương tự cho cái đoạn thứ hai
chúng ta cũng tiến hành là chia cột và
định dạng r chúng ta chọn đoạn
văn chúng ta thực hiện chia cột trước
chúng ta vào thẻ layout chọn column bây
giờ á là chúng ta sẽ chia hai cột nhưng
mà cột bên trái độ rộng nó nhỏ hơn cột
bên phải thì chúng ta sẽ chọn tương ứng
một led ở đây tuy nhiên giữa hai cái cột
nó có cái đường phân cách ở giữa đường
này
Line và để định dạng này thì chúng ta sẽ
chọn mục là m
colum m colum Sau đó chúng ta sẽ chọn
mục
l là định dạng cột bên trái độ rộng nó
nhỏ hơn cột bên phải Và tiếp tục chúng
ta chọn Line between Line between tức là
chúng ta đặt cái đường ở giữa hai
Cột rồi Kết thúc chúng ta chọn Ok là
xong chúng ta có cách chia
cột là cột bên trái độ rộng nhỏ hơn và
có đường phân cách ở giữa hai Cột bây
giờ tiếp tục chúng ta sẽ định dạng drop
cap chúng ta đặt C trỏ vào chữ
t vào thẻ
Insert chọn
dropcap và bây giờ chúng ta sẽ chọn mục
là drop cap option drop cap option có
nghĩa là chúng ta sẽ thực hiện một vài
các tùy chọn ở trong cái hội thoại dret
chúng ta nhắp chụt vào và trong hội
thoại này chúng ta sẽ chọn drop
x tiếp tục chúng ta có thể chọn Phong
chữ cho đối tượng drop
cat tức là cho chữ t không thôi và thứ
hai là l to drop l to drop Tức là cái ký
tự đó cái ký tự chữ T hoa đó nó rớt
xuống bao nhiêu dòng mặc định nó rớt
xuống ba dòng và tiếp theo là distance
from Test có nghĩa là khoảng cách từ cái
ký từ drop đến văn bản là bao nhiêu Bây
giờ mình minh họa nha Chúng ta chọn
Phong chữ chúng ta chọn một phong nào đó
đó ví dụ chúng ta chọn Phong nà chọn
Phong khác và tiếp tục l to drop chúng
ta có thể để I3 vậy cho nó cân đối dist
from test chúng ta tăng lên ví dụ chúng
ta tăng lên là 0,5 cm và chúng ta chọn
Ok
nha đây thì lúc này chữ t này n cái
phong chữ nó khác với phong chữ
chữ trước đó của nó cái thứ hai là
khoảng cách từ chữ t này đến văn bản
khoảng cách này là
0,5 cm chúng ta đã thiết lập
đây đó là định dạng drop cap tiếp tục
đoạn thứ ba chúng ta cũng làm tương tự
đoạn thứ ba thì chúng ta sẽ chia văn bản
ra ba cột và định dạng r ké chúng ta sẽ
chọn đoạn văn
vào layout chọn column nhớ rằng chúng ta
không chọn th ngay Vì chúng ta cần phải
có đường phân cách ở giữa các cái cột
này thì chúng ta chọn more colum và sau
đó chúng ta chọn th chúng ta chọn Line
between được
chưa trường hợp Chúng ta muốn ba cột này
độ rộng không bằng nhau thì chúng ta sẽ
bỏ cái mục
khoe colum qu đi bỏ cái khoe colum qu có
nghĩa là độ rộng ba các cột đó là như
nhau là bằng nhau chúng ta
bỏ và chúng ta có thể thay đổi này độ
rộng cột 1 là 4,87
Cm cột 2 cũng vậy cột 3 cũng vậy spacing
Là khoảng cách ở đây là 1,27 là khoảng
cách từ cột 1 đến cột cột 2 tiếp tục là
1,27 này là khoảng cách từ cột 2 đến cột
cột 3 bây giờ chúng ta thử chúng ta thay
đổi độ rộng của cột 1 này chúng ta tăng
độ rộng cột 1 lên
đây và
à giảm độ rộng cột ha này
đây và Như vậy là cột 1 là 5 cm cột 3 là
4,6 cột cột 2 là 4,6 cột 3 là 5 cm và
khoảng cách này chúng ta cũng có thể
thay đổi nha rồi Vậy kết thúc chúng ta
chọn Ok chúng ta có có được văn bản
thành 3 c và thao tác cuối cùng là chúng
ta sẽ cho là định dạng chữ B này là chữ
hoa rớt dòng gọi là
dropcap chúng ta đặt C trỏ vào chữ B vào
thẻ
Insert chọn drc và chọn drop
pick như vậy Kết thúc chúng ta có được
thao tác định dạng đoạn văn và định dạng
drop T
rồi video đến đây kết thúc Xin chào các
bạn